Guten Tag. Guten Tag.
Ich bin der zuständige Arzt für Sie, mein Name ist Emre Göktas.
Bevor wir anfangen, lassen Sie mich zuerst Ihren persönlichen Daten notieren.
Ja, klar. Dann besprechen wir über Ihre Bescheidung, okay? Ja, ja, ja.
Wie heißen Sie denn? Ich heiß Selma Schneider.
Selma Schneider. Okay. Mit Schneider mit E.I., ja? Ja, genau.
Gut, Frau Schneider, wie alt sind Sie? Ja, ich bin 63 Jahre alt.
61? Ratten Sie mir, dass Sie Ihr Geburtsraten? Ja, das ist der 22.08.58.
Wie groß sind Sie? Ich bin nur 1,56. Wie viel wiegen Sie?
Dafür wiege ich ein bisschen mehr. Ich wiege 82 Kilo. 89. Okay.
Sind Sie Verheiratet, Frau Schneider? Ja, ja, ja. Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, aber die sind natürlich schon groß, ne? Okay, wie viele Kinder haben Sie?
Drei, habe ich gehabt, ja. Drei Kinder. Okay.
Arbeiten Sie noch oder? Nein, ich war immer Hausfrau. Hausfrau, okay.
Ich habe mich auch nie rennt. Ich muss immer weiterarbeiten. Ja, genau.
So, klar, Schneider. Was kann ich für Sie tun? Ja, also genau genommen haben mich meine Freunde hierher gebracht.
Ich war heute Morgen mit denen unterwegs. Wir wollten eigentlich eine Fahrradtour machen.
Und da ist mir mit einmal ganz komisch geworden.
Mir ist ganz heiß geworden. Ich habe Schweißausbrüche bekommen.
Das Herz hat geklopft und ich war ganz kribbelig.
Und dann haben die gesagt, Mensch, Selma, was ist denn mit dir los?
Und dann, ja, bin ich vom Fahrrad abgestiegen.
Und dann habe ich mich erst mal hingesetzt und dann haben die mich gleich hier ins Krankenhaus gebracht.
Aber die nette Schwester in der Ambulanz, die hat mir ein Glas Cola gegeben.
Und seither geht es mir tatsächlich ein bisschen besser.
Okay, Frau Schneider, haben Sie aus dem Fahrrad gestürzt?
Nein, nein, nein, mir ist so schlecht geworden.
Okay, haben Sie Ihre Bewusstsein verloren in diesem Zeitraum?
Nein, nein, nein. Aber ich konnte tatsächlich nicht so gut gucken.
Die Sicht war mit einmal so verschwommen und was ganz komisch war.
Also die Arme haben richtig gezittert und auch die Arme und die Beine, da hatte ich so ein Kribbelgefühl.
Ich habe mich ganz unwohl gefühlt.
Und wissen Sie was? Ich bin ja mit meinen Freunden unterwegs gewesen.
Ich konnte nicht sagen, wie die heißen.
Also das war ganz erschreckend. Aber jetzt geht es mir zum Glück wieder besser.
Okay, verstehe.
Ist es noch irgendwelche Beschwörte? Haben die Brustschmerzen oder Atemlos?
Nein, so was habe ich alles nicht.
Das war nur in dem Augenblick, dass das Herz so doll geklopft hat, aber richtig Schmerzen oder Atemnot hatte ich nicht.
Okay, so was noch.
Okay, möchten Sie noch etwas hinzufügen oder möchte ich noch einfach über Ihre Vorgesteckte was fragen?
Ja, was möchten Sie denn noch wissen?
Ist Ihnen irgendwelche chronische Erkrankungen bekannt?
Ja, vor fünf Monaten hat man festgestellt, dass ich so ein Altersdiabetes habe.
Okay, nehme Sie dagegen Medikamente ein.
Ja, ich nehme ja immer Medikamente vor mir, morgens und abends.
Medikamente vor mir, morgens und abends.
Also heute haben Sie Ihre Medikamente eingenommen.
Ich habe das heute Morgen aufgenommen, ja.
Okay. Könnten Sie bitte genau sagen, wann haben Sie diese Beschwerden?
Wie viel war, ich meine?
Oh, ja, das war heute Morgen.
Ja, dann bin ich denn aufgestanden, dann habe ich ein bisschen was gefrühstückt, aber weil wir die Fahrradtour machen wollten, habe ich nicht so viel gegessen.
Damit ich nicht so einen vollen Magen habe.
Und als wir dann losgefahren sind, war das nach kurzer Zeit schon, dass es mir so schlecht ging.
Es war vielleicht so um 10 oder so.
Okay, haben Sie Kopfschmerzen gehabt?
Kopfschmerzen hatte ich nicht, nee.
Okay, außer der Metis.
Gibt es noch irgendwelche Erkrankungen?
Ja, das habe ich denn noch seit vor einem Jahr, hat der Atma festgestellt, dass ich so ein bisschen Herzstolpern habe.
Aber ich war da kürzlich zur Kontrolle und da war das eigentlich unauffällig.
Dann, ja, so Kleinigkeiten halt, vor zwei Jahren war der Unterschenkel mal sehr entzündet, da bin ich gestochen worden von irgendeinem Insekt.
Und da hatte ich mit einmal ganz tolle Entzündung im Bein.
Aber das ist Gott sei Dank dann wieder weggegangen.
Und dann habe ich was Blödes gerade in der einen Achselhöhe.
Da habe ich mir eine Pilzinfektion geholt und da muss ich jetzt immer so Antipilzsalbe auftragen.
Wissen Sie den Namen von Medikamenter?
Ja, das heißt Kanesthen, diese Salbe.
Kanesthen.
Okay, sind Sie schon mal operiert worden?
Ich bin noch nicht.
Vor fünf Jahren hatte ich mal einen Bruch im Sprunkel lenkt.
Das musste aber zum Glück nicht operiert werden, das ist mit einem Gips behandelt worden.
Aber Beschwerden habe ich da jetzt immer noch.
Beschwerden haben Sie immer noch?
Ja, der Ansatz ist ein bisschen Arthrose in den Beinen.
Okay, Sie haben gesagt, Sie haben Herzstolpe.
Sind Sie zum Kasiolosen vegan in der letzten Zeit?
Nein, aber beim Hausarzt war ich.
Und der hat mich durchgecheckt und der hat gesagt, dass das jetzt gerade gut ist.
Okay, nehmen Sie dagegen Medikamente rein oder?
Hallo, frage ich über Ihre Familienanwesen.
Gibt es in Ihrer Familie Wichtige Erkrankungen, wie Diabetes oder Bruthochdruck?
Ja, also meine Mutter, die hatte einen Schlaganfall, was da alles dahintersteckt,
aber die ist ja auch schon alt, die ist ja fast 90 Jahre alt.
Aber in meinen Händen ist sie ja richtig alt geworden.
Okay, was noch?
Sonst, mein Vater, der hatte eine Krebserkrankung und ist nicht sehr alt geworden.
Was du Krebs hast, hatte er?
Ja, das war was gar nicht so häufig, glaube ich, vorkommt.
Man hat uns das gesagt, das ist Nebenhodenkrebs.
Ich denke, okay, Sie sind schon in meiner Pause.
Ja, ja, ja klar. Das ist schon zehn Jahre.
Legen Sie regelmäßig zum Frauenarzt?
Ja, also vor knapp einem Jahr war ich zuletzt und da war alles in Ordnung
und bald habe ich wieder einen Termin.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Fieber habe ich jetzt nicht gemessen, aber ich fühle mich nicht fieberig.
Schlafen Sie gut?
Nein, ich schon, ja normalerweise.
Ich meine jetzt mit den...
Also, ist mir nicht aufgefallen, dass sie schlecht geschlafen hätte. Nein.
Heute Nacht habe ich auch gut geschlafen.
Ich habe mich auf unsere Fahrradtore freut.
Also, ja.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Ja, der ist immer gut, das sehen Sie ja.
82 Kilo wiege ich ja nicht umsonst.
Ja, das ist ein bisschen hoch, wie?
Deswegen, Sie sollten unbedingt abnehmen, ja.
Was sagen wir immer alle, ja.
Okay, habe ich...
Okay, haben Sie Probleme bei dem Stuhlgang oder Wasserlassen?
Nein, normalerweise eigentlich nicht.
Ist das etwas, was Sie sieblich belastet?
Das jetzt, dass ich da, dass mir da so schlecht geworden ist, das belastet mich natürlich,
aber ansonsten habe ich eigentlich...
keine Probleme.
Okay, gut.
Also, heiße Medikamente, ich erhole nochmal.
Sie nehmen, sie nehmen, regelmäßig mit Formin.
Zweimal.
Ja.
Wie viel Medikamente?
Mit Formin 500 steht da drauf.
Okay, und benutzen Sie auch Kanästin?
Kanästin-Salbe, ja, die muss ich zwar mal am Tag auftragen.
Und was noch?
Wenn ich Schmerzen habe in den Fuß, dann kann ich mal die Kloffinack nehmen.
Okay.
Wie viel Medikamente?
Oh, das weiß ich nicht.
Okay.
Brauchen Sie Klauschneider?
Ja, nur noch ein ganz bisschen.
Früher habe ich ja richtig viel geraucht, aber jetzt traue ich nur noch 6 Zigaretten an.
Das habe ich mich sehr eingeschränkt, ja.
Okay, wie viele Zigaretten vorher haben Sie geraucht?
Ja, also ich habe 40 Jahre lang richtig heftig geraucht,
da habe ich 15 Zigaretten am Tag geraucht.
Also kein ganzes Päckchen, aber 15 Stück, das war auch schon teuer genug, ja.
Genau, 40 Jahre lang.
Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Alkohol, ja.
Also insbesondere im Sommer trinke ich gerne mal ein Bier,
ein bis zwei Flaschen und jetzt im Winter ja vielleicht mal so ein Bier am Abend.
Okay.
Nehmen Sie Drogen?
Nein, habe ich noch nie genommen.
Gut.
Ist Ihnen Allergie bekannt?
Nicht, dass ich wüsste, nein, ja Allergien, bin auch nichts Allergisch.
Okay, Klauschneider.
Meineseits habe ich die wichtigste Fragen gestellt.
Wüssten Sie etwas hinzufügen oder haben Sie Fragen?
Ach, Sie haben ja so viel gefragt, aber ja, also wie kann ich das denn verhindern,
dass so was nochmal wieder passiert und wie kommt das denn?
Ja, Frau Schneider, ich verstehe Ihre Sorge,
aber um die richtige Diagnose fest, richtige Diagnose stimmen zu können,
brauchen wir noch einfach Untersuchung weiterer Untersuchung.
Deswegen kann ich Ihnen jetzt leider nicht sagen, was Sie haben
und wie können wir das behalten können,
aber deswegen brauchen wir erst mal weitere Untersuchungen.
Ja, was müssen Sie denn damit mit mir machen?
Ich würde Sie erst mal körperlich untersuchen, natürlich.
Danach, ich brauche auch eine Labo-Untersuchung.
Ich nehme Ihnen Volumaf.
Okay.
Und ich möchte auch eine Apparatil-Untersuchung, ich veranlöse eine Tomografie.
Was untersuchen Sie da bei der Tomografie?
Ja, Tomografie ist eine bildgebende Untersuchung.
Durch diese Untersuchung können wir die innere Organe und innere Gewebe
mit röntgen Darstellungen darstellen und die Funktion beurteilen.
Und was können Sie dann sehen?
Ja, ich möchte eine Tomografie, Tom-Coccity veranlassen.
Deswegen, ich möchte Ihre Gehirn untersuchen erst mal.
Ah, okay, ja.
Ja, das kann ich mir vorstellen.
Ist die Strahlbelastung dabei, Doll?
Ja, für diese Untersuchung müssen wir Röntgenbelastung benutzen.
Aber das ist nicht zu viel.
Die Experten sagen, ein Person dürfen 25-mal in ihrem Leben
diese Untersuchung durchführen lassen.
Ja, so alt will ich ja nicht werden.
Also, das sollen wir klappen.
Gut, ja, hat noch jemand Fragen dazu?
Vielleicht fragen wir so etwas auch.
Hör oder Seelstörungen haben Sie?
Die Frau hat gesagt, dass sie die Seelstörung hat.
Sie hat gesagt, sie hat verschwommen gesehen.
Ja, das habe ich mir gesehen.
Ja, gut, aber das hat sie beschrieben.
Und vielleicht, dass so eine Frage auch stellen,
haben Sie heute Morgen Frühstück und haben Sie eine gerettet,
damit Sie regelmäßig oder manchmal Ihre Blutsucke untersuchen.
Sie hat tatsächlich was dazu gesagt.
Sie hat erstens gesagt, dass sie das Medikament genommen hat.
Das hat er ja gefragt.
Er hat immer gefragt, haben Sie heute Morgen auch das Medikament genommen?
Und dann habe ich gesagt, ich wollte ja mit meinen Freunden auf die Fahrradtour.
Und weil ich gedacht habe, ich will nicht so einen vollen Magen haben,
habe ich nur ein bisschen gefrüstückt.
Aber das ist natürlich genau der Punkt.
Danke.
Sie sind auch immer auf der richtigen Pferde.
Sie kennt sich aus.
Gut, bist du schon so weit?
Ja.
Eigentlich ist es ja kein komplizierter Fall, oder?
Ja, kein komplizierter Fall.
Gut.
Ich habe eine neue Patientin.
Wenn Sie Zeit haben, ich möchte Ihnen die Patienten vorstellen.
Ja, gerne.
Die heißt Frau Schisselma Schneider.
Sie ist 83 Jahre alt.
Und sie ist 82 kg und 156 cm groß.
82 kg schwer und 56 kg groß.
Genau.
Und sie klagt über Frau Schneider.
Hatte heute Morgen eine Fahrradtour während dieser Tour.
Hatte sie folgende Beschwerden.
Ja, diese Beschwerden.
Tashkadi und hiparotrohosa,
und Kribbelgefühl,
Sie mussten auf dem Fahrrad absteigen und sie musste sich hinsetzen.
Sie ist zu uns gekommen und unsere Schwester hat ihr Cola gegeben und nachher fühlt sie sich besser.
Sie hat heute Morgen ihre Medikamente eingenommen.
Was nimmt sie denn da?
Med-for-Mean.
Sie nimmt nur Med-for-Mean, okay.
Ja, aber sie hat nicht viel gegessen.
In der Vorallkrankung gibt es noch Extrazistolen und eine Finns-Entfektion im Achselerbereich.
In der Familienanamnese liegt bei der Vater Apoplex und bei der Mutter Epidemiatino.
Sie ist auch da dran gestorben, oder?
Ja, okay.
Okay, Vegetative anamnese ist unauffällig und sie, wie ich gesagt habe, sie nimmt regelmäßig Med-for-Mean, 100 mg, morgens und abends ein.
Sie benutzt auch Kanistanzsalbe, morgens und abends nimmt sie Diplofonat, Tabletten ein und sie raucht 60 Zigaretten am Tag in der letzten Zeit.
Vorher hat sie 40 Jahre lang 50 Zigaretten am Tag geraucht.
Okay, ihr ist keine Allergie bekannt.
Okay, das war unser Patient.
Ja, was ist denn Ihre Verdachtdiagnose?
Also, nach den bisherigen Angaben gehe ich von Hypoglycemie aus, aber dafür sprechen sogenannte Sentome.
Aber, wie ich so weit ich weiß, mit Formie macht keine Hypoglycemie.
Ja, das hat nicht tatsächlich auch gewundert, aber so ist das halt.
Okay, gut.
Ja, aber was könnte, na gut, weil es hat sich wirklich so wenig gefrühstückt und hat sich angestrengt.
Und die finanziellen Diagnostik kommt zum Beispiel ein transporischer iskämischer Attack im Betrag.
Deswegen vielleicht für die Verdachtdiagnose transporische iskämische Attacke kann besser sein in diesem Fall.
Ich denke.
Ja, also wir müssten auf alle Fälle was diagnostisch machen.
Was würden Sie diagnostisch machen?
Unbedingt brauchen wir erstmal körperliche Untersuchungen.
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung müssen wir unbedingt neurologische Untersuchungen durchführen.
Stimmt, ja, sehr gut.
Ja, und Labordiagnostik ist wichtig, Glucoswerte, Blutzuckerwerte und was noch im Zündungparameter.
Großes Blutbild, das ist genug, glaube ich, erstmal.
Und brauchen wir auch eine City, in diesem Patienkopf.
Vom Kopf?
Ja, für welche Differenzialdiagnose?
Apoplex.
Ja, genau.
Und vielleicht können wir auch eine Apoplexphorografie, heißen Apoplexphorografie machen.
Ja, sehr gut.
Ja, gute Idee.
Gut, würden Sie auch einen EKG machen?
Ja, für diesen Kurpo und der Patient hat ein Herzstolpern, deswegen brauchen wir auch einen EKG.
Vielleicht hat der Patient eine Arithmie, dann hat die Patientin hatte eine Arithmie, dann hat sie eine chemische Attacke.
Okay, ja.
Gut, ja, ich bin gespannt, was bei Ihren Untersuchungen rauskommt.
Halten Sie mich doch bitte auf einem laufenden, was mit Frau Schneider weiter rauskommt, ja?
Okay.
Ja, wie noch jemand sich äußern zu Frau Schneider und zu Emre?
Ja, ich hatte ein bisschen Stress wegen dieser Verbindung und meiner Mutter, deswegen war ich ein bisschen riecheneinander.
Aber eigentlich alles gut.
Was mir nur aufgefallen ist, du machst konsequent immer noch dieselbe Geschichte, dass du, du bist nicht alleine, das machen fast alle.
Danach ich mache, ja?
Bitte andersrum, danach mache ich, ja?
Wenn was vorne wegkommt, dreht sich das um, ja?
Ich untersuche sie später, das kann man so richtig, dann ist es richtig, aber später untersuche ich sie.
Ja, es ist nun mal so, ja.
Gut, aber ansonsten war das doch wieder eine Top Anamnese.
Und ich finde immer sprachlich sind die, sind die, die Arzt-Patientgespräche ein bisschen normaler,
aber das liegt auch an meiner Aversion gegen diese komische Formulierung, die in diesen Arztgesprächen ja so gefordert wird.
Ja, ich finde, die ist so unnormal.
Ja, kein Mensch würde sagen, die Patientin stellt sich vor mit heute Morgen aufgetretenem Tra-la-la-Hops-Sauser, ja?
Sondern man würde sagen, ja, die Patientin ist von ihren Freunden hier in die Klinik gebracht worden.
Man würde wahrscheinlich tatsächlich erst mal sagen, seit fünf Monaten ist bei deren Diabetes bekannt.
Und der ist eigentlich bisher mit Metformin eingestellt, aber die hatte heute Morgen typische Symptome einer Hypoglykemi.
Ja, und nämlich, sie hatte Herzrasen, Schweißausbrüche, Kribbeln in den Beinen, Tra-la-la.
Also, dann beschreibt man das alles.
Aber es wird ja gefordert, diese komische Formulierung, dass in Realität läuft die Prüfung auch nicht so.
Die Prüfer hat immer Fragen, zum Beispiel Unterricht, unser Gespräch.
Okay, und frag noch etwas.
Okay, okay, ich weiß das.
Und was ist deine Verdacht, Jarnoze?
Warum denken Sie das?
Wir mussten nicht alles vorstellen, ja?
Rauchgenussmittel oder Allergie oder so weiter.
Die möcht auch nicht das.
Okay, ja.
Gut, dann ist es ja tatsächlich eine relativ authentische Prüfungssituation.
Aber natürlich müsst ihr das alles fragen.
Und was ich eigentlich interessant finde, das habe ich jetzt bei den Düsseldorferfällen.
Da gibt es ein großes Einleitungspaket an Informationen.
Wahnsinn, wirklich so viel Stoff zum Lesen.
Da steht tatsächlich ganz explizit drin.
Fragen sind nur solche Fragen, die wirklich im Zusammenhang stehen.
Also, wenn jetzt jemand mit einem gebrochenen Bein kommt, dann ist tatsächlich die Nachfrage,
was ich nach der Familienanalyse mehr oder weniger müßig.
Selbst wenn der Vater oder die Mutter sich auch mal das Bein gebrochen hat,
hat es nichts hier mit zu tun.
Ja, ja.
Und da ist irgendwie auch, ja, der Familienstand ist vielleicht nur insofern wichtig,
dass man jemanden informieren muss und wie der Patient zu Hause versorgt ist.
Aber alles andere, ne?
Und also, wenn ich, ja, klar, kann ich da nochmal fragen,
ob der Unternyktorileidet, aber das hat eigentlich keine Relevanz für das gebrochene Bein.
Ja, und auch jetzt bei dieser Patientin, ob die jetzt nachts zum Klo geht oder nicht,
das hat keinen Einfluss darauf, ob sie morgen zum Fahrrad fällt, mit der Hypoglycemie.
Es ist also, ja.
Aber das ist halt ein bisschen untypisch, die Situation, die wir in der Simulation haben.
Ja.
Gut.
Du hast ja die Fälle selber. Du kannst ja nochmal nachlesen.
Ja, ja, ich muss nochmal hören und nachlesen.
Ja, und ja, ich glaube aber, also, bei dir habe ich echt keine Sorgen, dass die Prüfung läuft.
Ja, die sprachlichen Feinheiten, wo ich so ein bisschen pissellig bin, ja,
das wird den Prüfern echt egal sein, denke ich.
Ja, und du bist so sicher unterwegs mit der Sprache,
dass du ganz bestimmt keine Schwierigkeiten hast.
Gut, gut.
Aber ich freue mich natürlich, dass ich dir heute einen Meinstab halten kann.
Gut.
Ja.